hola que tal pienso que probablemente
estés familiarizado con la idea de lo
que es una raíz cuadrada pero me
gustaría aclarar un poco con respecto a
la notación por lo menos pues casi
siempre parece un tanto amigo la primera
vez que escuchamos este término entonces
si escribimos por aquí lo que es la raíz
cuadrada de 9 si te das cuenta tenemos
un signo que está expresando nos lo que
es la raíz un signo radical y debajo
ponemos el número 9 entonces lo que hace
esta operación es que queremos calcular
la principal raíz de 9 la raíz principal
de 9 entonces a qué me refiero con la
raíz principal de 9 bueno quizás tú me
podrás decir que yo estoy tratando de
ser demasiado clara pero que tú ya
sabías que la raíz cuadrada de 9 puede
ser tanto menos 3 como más 3 así es que
cuando nosotros ponemos el signo radical
o cuando tratamos de expresar una raíz
cuadrada este resultado nos pueda
arrojar tanto una raíz positiva como una
raíz negativa
pero si tú simplemente escribe es un
signo radical te estás refiriendo
simplemente a la raíz principal a la
raíz positiva si te quisieras referir a
la raíz negativa de hecho podría ponerle
un signo de menos que estuviera antes de
dicho de dicho signo que expresa nuestra
raíz entonces si vemos por aquí podemos
poner la menos raíz cuadrada de 9 y
entonces el resultado ahí sería menos 3
pero en ambos casos pues se tiene un
resultado correcto entonces la mejor
forma para tratar de expresar ambas
partes es que puedas poner más menos la
raíz cuadrada de 9 y entonces sabemos
que el resultado va a ser más menos 3
pero bueno ahora por otro lado algo que
también me gustaría tocar en este vídeo
es como sea la gráfica de las funciones
entonces supongamos que tenemos la
siguiente función y es igual a la ra
x y luego tuviéramos la función que es
igual a ye igual por aquí tenemos ya
igual a la raíz de xy luego la función
que voy a poner por acá
igual a equis cuadrada y bueno la idea
de tener estas dos funciones que
pretendo que más adelante las
intercambiamos para obtener un mejor
entendimiento de dichas funciones las
vamos a intercambiar de izquierda a
derecha así que realicemos una pequeña
tabla en la cual iremos evaluando dichas
funciones o calculando valores para cada
una de nuestras funciones para después
lograr graficar y ver cuánto equivale
cada valor y entonces yo poderte
explicar que es a lo que yo quiero
llegar entonces por aquí tenemos las xy
entonces veamos si damos valores vamos a
dar valores positivos para nuestra
función por aquí tenemos el 0 y entonces
cuando x vale 0 0 al cuadrado sería 0
entonces que vale 0 luego si x es igual
a 1 1 al cuadrado es 1 entonces es igual
a 1 cuando x es igual a 2 2
al cuadrado es 4 y es igual a 4 y luego
vamos a darle un valor más si x es igual
a 3 al cuadrado es 9 y entonces es igual
a 9 y bueno finalmente para tener una
gráfica un poco mejor 4 al cuadrado es
16 y estos son los valores de mi primer
función ahora yendo a nuestra función y
igual a la raíz de x veamos que tanto
tienen en similar y bueno para este caso
en esta función quizás no tome valores
tan arbitrarios voy a tomar valores con
un propósito el chiste es que quiero
comparar ambas funciones y también
después genera una gráfica que sea un
tanto similar entonces si te das cuenta
simplemente estoy sustituyendo cuando x
es igual a 1 ponemos x igual a 1 y la
raíz de uno es 1 entonces vale 1 y luego
bien si tenemos el siguiente valor 4 la
raíz cuadrada de 4x igual a 4 es igual a
2 ya igualados
de 9 sería 3 pues 3 x 39 entonces es
igual a 3 y finalmente la raíz cuadrada
de 16 sería 44 por 4 16 y entonces aquí
lo tenemos pero ahora piensa en cómo
puedes ir relacionando estas cosas si te
das cuenta 2 al cuadrado es 4 y luego
vemos que la raíz cuadrada de 4 es 2
luego 3 al cuadrado se convierte de 9 y
la raíz cuadrada de 9 es igual a 3 luego
4 al cuadrado es igual a 16 y la raíz
cuadrada 10 16 es 4 entonces ahora todo
tiene sentido es cómo sacar raíz
cuadrada de ambas partes de una ecuación
entonces tendríamos por aquí que ya
cuadrada es igual a equis y por supuesto
si quisiéramos restringir el dominio de
jay para puros y es positivo estado que
esto solamente puede tomar valores
positivos al ser la raíz cuadrada
principal entonces en general la idea es
sólo intercambiar estas equis y éstas
entre
la función entonces una es una función
de aquí y la otra es para esta función
de por acá
y si asumiremos un dominio para xy para
dispositivos tendríamos el siguiente
cuadrante para poder graficar solamente
tendremos el cuadrado de positivo
entonces ahora sí graficando primero
tenemos el punto cero cero el punto 1,1
quería por aquí pero mi escala es
demasiado especialmente desde flower
haciendo por unidades para que me
alcance toda mi toda mi recta que espero
nos quede bien entonces por aquí tenemos
estos puntos 14 15 y queremos hasta 16
para que alcance a cubrir todo luego
nuestro eje de las leyes tenemos las
siguientes unidades y de igual forma
queremos que nuestro eje que llegue
hasta 16 entonces estas son estos son
nuestros ejes y ahora sí vamos a lo
siguiente tenemos primero el 0 0 luego
el 1,1 luego el 2,4 que estaría más o
menos por aquí luego sigue
es 9 entonces tenemos 39 por aquí y
finalmente el punto 4 16 la coordenada 4
16 entonces ahora sí trazando nuestra
gráfica vemos que luce de la siguiente
forma nuestra gráfica va a lucir algo
así muy bien eso fue esta es nuestra
gráfica para nuestra función y es igual
a x cuadrada ahora cómo va a lucir
nuestra gráfica de la función que es
igual a la raíz de x de igual forma
partimos del 0,0 del 11 luego es 4,2 que
es por aquí luego 9,3 que viene siendo
por acá
16 4 x igual a 16 4 y entonces el punto
es por acá y al unirlo nos luce algo así
y si lo llegas a notar o eres muy
observador ves o puedes alcanzar a
percibir que estas gráficas son como un
espejo en realidad están siendo
simétricas si partiéramos cuando tenemos
la recta x igual allí entonces
simplemente es como un espejo son muy
similares y como lo había dicho te
hacemos por aquí nuestra recta identidad
o cuando x es igual a ye y vemos que en
realidad son simétricas pero bueno esto
es lo que yo hice a mano podemos ver
esto muchísimo mejor cuando tenemos el
apoyo de una gráfica ahora en realidad
está tú la puedes encontrar en internet
yo lo busqué simplemente y bueno
enredado hay que tratar de dar como todo
su crédito debido a esta página que yo
encontré en internet para que también tú
la utilices entonces la página sería m y
punto
hrw v puntocom
06 y bueno creo que estamos listos para
utilizarla entonces por aquí vamos a
hacer nuestra primera función vamos a
graficar nuestra primera función de
color rojo sería la de x cuadrada y
luego aquí en el color verde vamos a
meter nuestra raíz de xy si te das
cuenta de este lado del lado derecho
tenemos todo lo necesario para utilizar
al tratar de poner nuestras funciones
vamos a entrar esto y bueno
graficando lo vemos que el color rojo
nos gráfica nuestra función x cuadrada y
el verde es la raíz de x si lo
comparamos con nuestra gráfica de que
hice a mano vemos que coincide si
solamente nos fijáramos en el cuadrante
positivo de nuestra gráfica ahora
entonces en realidad nos quedó bastante
bien lo que hicimos a mano pero
obviamente queda mucho mejor cuando se
mete en este tipo de programas son
bastante útiles y muy bien ahora que ya
gráfica mos estas primeras funciones
vamos a jugar un poco solamente por
diversión
veamos qué pasaría si vamos cambiando un
poco la escala
nuestras gráficas entonces ahora en
lugar de que fuera simplemente x
cuadrada nuestra función qué pasa si la
multiplicas por 2 y le cambias la escala
y luego también le pones un escalar un
poco más chico que uno qué tal si le
ponemos punto 5 que multiplica nuestra
función x cuadrada y lo gráfica mos como
podrás ver ambos tipos de escalas siguen
siendo para volar sin embargo el que
tenemos de color verde si te das cuenta
crece un poco más rápido o se corre un
poco más rápido pues nuestro escalar lo
hace así y si te das cuenta esta gráfica
azul al ser nuestro escalar menor que 1
nos está haciendo más lenta nuestra
apertura de la parábola pero eso no es
todo
aquí lo que hicimos fue simplemente
multiplicar por algún por algún real o
por azar por algún real que nos cambie
la escala de nuestra gráfica pero ahora
qué pasaría si más bien como que la
quieres recorrer
izquierda oa la derecha podemos poner
que si la queremos recorrer hacia la
derecha 4 unidades le restamos 4 a equis
y le vamos al cuadrado y luego x + 2 al
cuadrado o sea recorrer nuestra para
volar a la izquierda y si te das cuenta
es justo como te lo dije al restarle 4
estamos recorridos 4 unidades a la
derecha y al sumarle dos estamos
recorridos 2 unidades hacia la izquierda
ahora quizás no te suene un tanto
intuitivo que al restar el 4 estemos 4 a
la derecha y al sumarle dos estemos 2 a
la izquierda pero veamos qué sucede si
sustituye es aquí cuando x es igual a 4
que es donde parten nuestro vértice
entonces esto se hace igual a 0 sería
como 4 menos 4 igual a 0 y luego para x
igual a menos 2 si lo sustituye en
nuestra función de aquí también
tendríamos menos 2 más 2 al cuadrado
sería 0 entonces es equivalente aparte
de el vértice que tenemos de nuestra
principal función que parte del origen
simplemente estamos recorriendo unidades
a la izquierda o a la derecha y otra
forma de pensar lo puede hacer cuando x
es igual a 1 en este punto de nuestra
parábola roja es similar para cuando x
es igual a 5 para nuestra parábola verde
pues tendríamos 5 menos 4 igual a 1 x
igual a 1 entonces sería similar por acá
entonces tienes el mismo punto en la
parábola entonces ahora sí luce más
intuitivo todo esto y tiene muchísimo
más sentido a como lo veíamos en un
inicio y bien también algo muy
interesante sería recorrer nuestras
gráficas para arriba o para abajo
entonces si queremos cambiar la curva
para arriba viste que sube un +1 para mi
gráfica roja ahora ciudad recorro cinco
unidades para abajo a nuestra gráfica
verde simplemente le restamos cinco
unidades y también podrías multiplicarlo
por punto 5 nuestra gráfica
y recorrer las 5 unidades hacia abajo o
sea puedes cambiarle la escala y también
recorrerla o moverla a la izquierda oa
la derecha puedes hacer lo que tú gustes
con nuestras gráficas y es similar para
cuando tenemos nuestras funciones de la
raíz ahora veamos qué pasa con las
raíces tenemos la raíz de x luego vamos
a tener nuestra raíz recorrida 5
unidades de las de la derecha y luego
tenemos nuestra raíz recorrida 4
unidades hacia la izquierda y recorrida
3 unidades hacia abajo entonces
graficándolo vemos que en rojo tenemos
nuestra raíz de x y ésta es casi igual
simplemente la recorremos cinco unidades
de la derecha es prácticamente lo mismo
el vértice es el mismo simplemente esta
recorrida y la azul como podrás darte
cuenta la recorrimos cuatro unidades
hacia la izquierda pero aparte le
restamos unidades para que se recorrerá
hacia abajo entonces nuestra gráfica
azul
de algo así y también si quisiéramos que
esta última gráfica aparte de esta
recorrida de estas unidades también
quisiéramos que haberá un poquito más
lento también podríamos cambiarle la
escala o podríamos hacerla un tanto
estrecha entonces déjame hacer eso y
también lo haré para esta entonces
tendríamos lo siguiente tenemos punto
cinco por nuestra raíz de x-men más
cuatro menos tres unidades luego tres
por nuestra raíz de x menos cinco y lo
gráfica nos y vemos cómo cambian ahora
abre un poco más lento es un tanto más
éste estrecha a nuestra función de color
azul y la de color verde abre mucho más
rápido y vemos que está de la siguiente
forma lo último que le hice a nuestra
gráfica de color verde fue recorrerla
ahora cuatro unidades hacia arriba y
vemos que éstas no pueden ser
completamente parábolas puesto que
simplemente nos estamos fijando en la
raíz principal que es lo que deseamos
hacer ratito en la raíz
pero estas también podríamos completar
les la raíz aunque tendrían los puntos
equis tendrían como un doble valor y
será un poco complicado por lo tanto
simplemente tomamos las raíces positivas
de entrada